president biden signing three new
executive orders today all related to
immigration this is the second time the
president
has focused on that topic since taking
office
christian kazar is joining us live from
our 8 news now newsroom
on what this means christian that's
right brian well president biden focused
on three areas in his executive orders
the unification of families separated
at the border a review of the asylum
policies and a reverse
on the previous administration's
immigration agenda three areas that we
know will not cause immediate change now
let's start with the task force which
will focus on reuniting the estimated
600 plus
children that were separated two years
ago from their families along the border
during the previous administration many
of those parents
were deported to mexico and central
america president biden called this
the national shame of the previous
administration's immigration policies
mr biden also will review trump's
administration's
remaining mexico policy which required
about 700 000 asylum seekers to wait
outside the u.s territory
while their cases were educated making
sure
that he's actually keeping promises that
he made
during the campaign trial and i think
that's very very important i think one
of the most important
policies for me right now is the fact
that he is going to develop
that task force to make sure that he's
reuniting those families that were
actually separated
um over under the trump administration
well the white house officials say the
reuniting of families will be a
case-by-case basis separated families
could be
eligible for parole visas or other
immigration benefits to enable
their reunification now again
the immediate immediate change according
to white house
will not take any sort of immediate
effect but local pro-immigrant groups
that we talked to
are very hopeful about the direction the
president is heading it's only been a
few weeks and they say it seems
immigration is obviously a top priority
for the white house
we'll be back after this break